[Music]
so today we're gonna try a new form of
yoga I don't know what it is
I've done yoga a few times before I
can't be still it can be calm that's one
of the main uses will have never tried
yoga yoga is a really great outlet for
me to decompress I'm excited to try it
let's let's do it so today we're gonna
surprise a group of Yogi's with baby
goats for what we call goat yoga yoga we
kind of just integrate the mind with the
body with the breath we did a few
different positions in the beginning
that were just really basic and really
simple there wasn't really anything that
I haven't done before nothing happened
for a while and so I just bought into it
so relax and feel good when you're ready
just close your eyes another really big
thing in yoga is that we're in a
constant state of change right there's
good things happening bad things
happening yeah that's gonna happen alive
everything I dreamed up though Yoga is
nothing different than taking your dog
for a walk you're bonding with that
animal and you're getting exercise
it's my form of the new animal assisted
therapy
it just makes people forget all the hard
things they're going through when we
would like go down they would jump on
your back
I felt like my muscles just relaxing
with each step that they took baby goats
are really just playful animals and
they're not afraid to connect with you
[Music]
Yoga is really good for your mental
health anyways but adding an animal to
the mix exponentially increases that
although I couldn't really focus on the
yoga part because the goats were just so
cute it works that way too because the
whole point of yoga is just to relax
your mind and be happy about your
surroundings which exactly was what I
was feeling
animals in general that make me feel at
peace you know like when I pet my dog
and just playing with this goats make me
feel so good I completely forgot about
the outside world there should be more
types of exercise incorporating animals
into them because they make us happy
they're in pure ingenuine a lady who had
breast cancer just to the fact that that
though could make her happy
and after all she's been through I
really think there's just a healing
quality about that human animal bond
[Music]